what do you guys think how do you know
when a guy's a good guy
I don't know what when what what the
mind them all good yeah yeah yeah yeah
yo you know what it is with the you know
you can tell when the a man is in line
when he has a good woman
a good woman makes a good man no but
he's not good on his own first okay
stop please stop please stop now I asked
you guys for her she's a single woman or
sort of she's dating someone but like
for a single woman how do you know if
it's a good man what do you think do you
think it's easy to tell as a guy who the
guy good guys are no it's not easy it's
not if he's willing to accept your
trauma he's a good guy hmm that's a good
one that's a good one
definitely because really that's a good
point yes
he's actually there like raw like cool
you've gone let's say all right what
kind of example can I do maybe working
or not trying to work around you in a
way whatever the issue may be or
whatever it is going through yeah like
if she needs time like you're there but
you're you're you're supportive your
support it's not just how do you think I
feel like
fundamentally I think that all most guys
a good guy you know good guys we are
good guys yeah yeah I agree no um but
the thing is it's about have we found
the right woman okay so if we're with
the right woman then it works if we're
not that it's not about how does she see
it though and she's not going to see it
um easily because it depends on who she
is all right this is what I just said to
Pearl it's about but she doesn't
understand do you see me saying it from
a man like
in order for a man to be a good man you
have to have a good woman because the
woman will put you in line like man on
their own don't put themselves in line
we do reckless things we buy we spend
money recklessly we live recklessly
until you get that good one I was
chatting to remind them today in the
what's up group and it's like well you
could even remember was saying about a
man dressing well you could tell when a
man's dressing a certain way in a
relationship and out of a relationship
you can tell obviously I don't know
Magnum guitar I don't know if women can
tell but really the most like Dependable
like responsible man I know don't really
need a woman to like look after them not
to be honest it's not about need it's
about guidance so like I mean do you get
what I'm saying no because I'm just
thinking about the men like I respect
the most in my life that I really like
doing stuff um like I think of my dad
some of my brothers they don't need a
woman to like guide them or take care of
them they kind of have a path stuff they
want to do they don't really no we're
always going to have a part of it but
women have certain like we're practical
so we're always on your we need to do
this we need to do that when blah blah
where women are more
structured they will put their men are
structured but we will got weasels we'll
see we'll have a vision and we go for
that vision and sometimes we just go
because we can see what we're going for
we know we we got the picture in our
head but a woman a woman can organize
the route a bit better than a man
couldn't organize them I think what
you're saying is more like enhancing
your qualities enhancing your life yeah
maybe yeah but like honestly for me I
think that if if a guy can get up even
when he's sad when he has a bad day
maybe if he likes to work out he'll do a
workout go to work not be emotional all
the time you know these things that if
you already do them without a woman
that's good yeah we do that naturally
but go on Pro yeah I know you he was um
it's just this just sounds to me yeah
like the guys you don't want to date
which is the guys that like need a woman
yeah to like to guide them yeah yeah
like I would think you'd want like a
leader or maybe I'm wrong no no man's a
leader yeah
I'm just an organized man's paperwork
while um
[Music]
you're kind of switching what you
started saying no I hate what you know
but I'm okay it's hard for me to explain
it because it's like
it's mad because obviously man I'm I'm
when I'm saying I'm focused man you can
be focused on something but sometimes
you need somebody there to help you in
line certain things because man we will
just do things like for example are you
shopping for example yeah
[Music]
if they want a dress or something or
they want to choose to try it on it's
got to make sure it looks right blah
blah update oh they will pattern up
things make sure everything's correct
before they leave that did you get what
I'm saying but how does that happen get
in your size eight better
your Earth was better someone is getting
my Air Force better so is that because
she organizes your route
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible